สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีครู
เรียมเจอกันวันนี้วันพฤหัสค่ะวันพฤหัสบ
โอเคใช่พฤหัสของประเทศไทยนะคะประเทศไทย
ใช่เมื่อกี้ตอนูเรียนบอกพฤหัสคุณนิก็ดู
ว่าเอ๊ะอ๋อเราอยู่คนละที่วันมันไม่เหมือน
กันใช่เอแล้ววันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่วัน
ที่ 29 ค่ะอ่าโอเคเดือนอะไรครับเดือน
กันยายนค่ะ
อืปีพ.ศอะไรครับพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
อืแล้วปีค.ศอะไรครับค.ศ 2020  12 อื
โอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วที่ตอนนี้ที่ไทย 9 น
1 นครับ 99:00 นค่ะอืเราพูดกันบ่อยๆนะ
ว่าเป็นวัน
พฤหัสแต่วันเต็มๆอ่ะที่พูดแบบยาวๆต้องยาว
ๆเนาพฤหัสสบดีแล้วคนไทยก็จะชอบพูดกันว่า
อ๋อวันพฤหัสดีอ่ะไม่สระผมนะเพราะสระบ่ดี
บ่ดีก็ไม่ดีไม่ใช่ขี้เกียจขี้เกียจสะขี้
เกียจใช่วันพุธตัดผมไม่ได้พฤหัสก็สะบ่ดี
อืไม่ไม่ทำอะไรกับผมเลยดีกว่าใชใช่ต้อง
บอกต้องบอกนักเรียนก่อนว่าคำว่าบ่อเนี่ย
มันเป็นภาษา1ึนะแปลว่าไม่เดี๋ยวนักเรียน
จะงงว่าเ้าทำไมพระภาษาเหนือก็พูดบ่อนะอื
อืเหนือและอีสานใช่มั้ยใช่เหนืออีสานบ่อ
ก็
ไม่อืมใช่คุณนิกก็จะติดพูดคำว่าบ่อกับ
เพื่อนเพราะว่าแม่คุณนิกมาจากลำพูนแล้ว
คุณนิกก็จะได้ยินบ่อยพเวลาเพื่อนพูดอะไร
ที่เป็นเกี่ยวกับไหมๆๆคนนี้ก็จะใช้คำว่า
บอกอืใช่มหลายคนก็ใช้ขนาดคนที่อยู่ภาค
กลางก็ยังพูดเลยว่าบ่อดีบ่อไปบางทีอ่ะนะ
ก็แปลว่าไม่ไม่ดีไม่ไปใช่ๆก็บอกไว้ว่านัก
เรียนจะได้รู้ว่าอ๋อแปลว่าอะไรทำไมเกี่ยว
อะไรกับทำไมพฤหัสสระบ
ดีได้เรียนรู้ภาษาเพิ่มภาษาเพิ่มใช่ใช่
ครับเนี่ยครูเรียมตอน
เนี้ยโทรศัพท์คุณนิกอ่ะมันไม่ค่อยดีอื
เออมันไม่พดีแล้วครูนิกอ่ะก็คิดว่าคือตอน
แรกคิดว่าจะไปซื้อโทรศัพท์ใหม่อืม
อืแสดงว่าตอนนี้เปลี่ยนใจเหรอคะเปลี่ยนใจ
หรอคือตอนแรกเนี่ยอยากซื้อโทรศัพท์ใหม่
เพราะว่าโทรศัพท์ที่ครุูนิกใช้เครื่อง
เนี้ยใช้
มามากกว่า 4 ปีละอืก็นานอยู่นะ 4 ปีนาน
ใช่ครับแต่ว่าเพราะเพราะว่ามันนานแล้วมัน
ก็มีเหมือนกับมีรูปแล้วก็มันเหมือนกับเมม
อ่ะเมมในโทรศัพท์ความจำมันมันเต็มแล้วพอ
ความจำมันเต็มเวลาใช้โทรศัพท์เปิด
อินเทอร์เน็ตเข้าเว็บมันก็จะช้าเหมือนคน
ไทยจะบอกว่าเหมือนมันอืดแบบรอนานคว่าล
เน็ตแล้วก็ใช้แบบกับแบบเน็ตอืดมากมากใช่
ขับรถอืดมากคือช้ามากใช่คือมันช้ามากอะไร
มันก็อืดไปหมดอืใช่อ้าแล้วครูนี้ก็ต้อง
ซื้อสิคะครูนี้ซื้อใหม่ไปเลยใช่ก็ตอนแรก
เนี่ยก็จะซื้อใหม่แต่ว่ามันมันแพง
อ่ะทำไมอ่ะครูนิกอยากได้รุ่นไหนหรือเปล่า
โทรศัพท์รุ่นไหนข้อไหนคือคือุคุณนิกอ่ะ
ใช้ iPhone แล้วคุณนิกก็ไม่อยากเปลี่ยน
เป็นยี่ห้ออื่นเพราะใช้ iPhone มาหลายปี
แล้วแล้วรู้สึกว่าโอเคโอเคกับโอเคกับ
Apple อืใช่เพราะว่าเหมือนกับคุณนิก็มี
อย่างคอมคุณนิก็ใช้ของ Apple เหมือนกัน
มันก็เลยเหมือนกับมันต่อกันง่ายอืมตัวนี้
ก็เลยไม่อยากเปลี่ยนแต่ว่ามันแพงตอนเนี้ย
คุณนิก็เลยมาคิดว่าหรือจะ
รออีกปี
นึงรอให้โทรศัพท์รุ่นที่เราอยากได้ราคา
มันลดลงหรอคะหรือว่ายังไงแค่รอดูว่าถ้า
มันมีอะไรที่น่าสนใจกว่านี้หรือคุณนี้อาจ
จะเปลี่ยน
ใจไปใช้โทรศัพท์ยี่ห้ออื่นที่ไม่ใช่ Apple
ก็ได้เพราะว่าตอนนี้รู้สึกว่า iPhone
ราคามันแพงขึ้นทุกปีทุกปีใช่ๆแต่ถ้าเปิด
ถ้าเป็นรุ่นที่แบบไม่ได้ใหม่นะอเป็นแบบ
อาจจะตกรุ่นลงมานิดนึงก็ราคาก็เรวว่าก็
ไม่ไม่ได้ถือว่าแพงแต่ว่าก็แพงอยู่แหละ
ไม่กล้าพูดว่าไม่แพงราคามันจะถูกลงกว่า
ปกติเหมือนอย่างกรุ่นใหม่ออกมาขาย 30,000
พอรุ่นใหม่ออกมาแล้วก็จะลงเหลือ
25,000 หรือ
27,000 ประมาณเนี้ยครับใช่อืก็จะถูกลงมา
แต่ก็แค่คครูนิกเหมือนกับเสียดายเงิน
เพราะว่าปกติเวลาครูนิกใช้ของเงี้ยซื้อ
ของครูนิก
จะส่วนใหญ่ใช้คำว่าส่วนใหญ่ดีกว่าครููนิ
จะใช้นาน
อืมใช่มีอะไรบ้างคะที่ครูนิใช้แล้วก็แบบ
ใช้นานมากก็โทรศัพท์สำหรับคุณนิกนะคุณนิก
คิดว่าโทรศัพท์แล้วก็
คอมพิวเตอร์อือื
ใช่ก็คอมพิวเตอร์ครูนิกเนี่ยอย่างน้อยนะ
อย่างน้อยคือ 5 ปี
อืที่ครูนี้เคยใช้แล้วแบบนานที่สุดเกี่
ปีเคยใช้นานที่สุดมีอยู่มีคอมพิวเตอร์จำ
ได้เลยอันนี้เป็นคอมพิวเตอร์โตชิใช้ 10
ปี
หูนานานใช่คือใช้ตั้งแต่มหามหาวิทยาลัย
เลยจนทำ
งาน
จนคือมันก็อยู่ที่บ้านแล้วก็พอได้งาน
เนี่ยก็ใช้น้อยลงพอใช้น้อยลงแต่ก็ยังใช้
อยู่แต่ก็นั่นแหละครับเกือบ 10 ปีจนซื้อ
เครื่อง
ใหม่อืโสุดยอดครูนิเป็นคนที่ใช้ของคุ้ม
มากแต่มันไม่ใช่ทุกอย่างนะเพราะว่าคือ
อย่างถ้าเป็นของใช้แบบเนี้ยโทรศัพท์
คอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ยคุณนิก็จะใช้นานเวลา
เปลี่ยนแล้วเหมือนมันเสียดายแต่ถ้าเป็น
เสื้อผ้าเนี่ยเสื้อผ้าคุณนิกจะใส่ประมาณ 1
ปีถึง 1 ปีครึ่ง
อ๋อมก็ถือว่านานอยู่นะนานมั้ยนานแต่เรียม
ใช้ได้นานกว่า
นั้นคือคืออ่าอย่างคุณครูเรียมทำไมครู
เรียม
ถึงคิดว่าคือจะบอกว่ายังไงดีคือสาเหตุที่
ครูนิกเนี่ยถ้าเป็นเสื้อผ้าครูนิกเปลี่ยน
คือพยายามที่จะเปลี่ยนทุกปีเพราะว่าครู
นิกรู้สึกว่าคุณภาพมันเริ่มเก่าแล้วคุณ
นี้คิดว่าถ้าซื้อใหม่เนี่ยมันก็ได้ของ
ใหม่มาแล้วเราอ่ะเอาเสื้อผ้าที่เราคิดว่า
เก่าเนี่ยคุณนี้ิเอาไปบริจาคนะไม่ได้เอา
ไปทิ้งอืเพราะคุณนี้ิก็รู้ว่ามันยังไม่
ได้แย่มันใช้แค่ 1 ทีคุณภาพเนี่ยถ้าเรา
มองว่ามันคุณภาพมันแย่ลงแต่สำหรับคนอื่นเ
ยังใช้ได้คุณนี้ก็เลยว่าเอาไปบริจาคดี
กว่าพอบริจาคเราก็ไปซื้อเสื้อผ้าใหม่แล้ว
ก็ได้เหมือนกับตัวใหม่ที่มันไม่ได้ซัก
บ่อยๆเพราะว่า
เสื้อผ้าที่เราใช้ถ้าเราซักบ่อยมันก็
เหมือนกับมันจะค่อยๆเปื่อยอ่ะใช่ๆเป็นแบบ
นั้นแหละเออนั่นเหมือนกางเกงมีกางเกงตัว
นึงที่เรียมใส่ออกกำลังกายแล้วเรียมชอบ
มากแล้วมันจะเป็นเชือกผูกค่ะครูนิกครับ
เป็นกางเกงใช่มยกางเกงที่มีเชือกเชือกผูก
ตรงเนี้ยอืเรียมแบบชอบใส่มากจนจนจนตรง
เนี้ยมันขาดอ่ะแล้วมันก็แบบห้อยอยู่กับ
เชือก
ผูกแล้วก็แบบวันนึงเรี้งก็คิด
ว่าทำไมเราถึงยังใส่กางเกงตัวนี้อยู่ทั้ง
ที่แบบมันก็ไม่จะผูกไม่อยู่อยู่แล้วอะไร
อย่าเงี้ยเหมือนยางมันยืดแล้วด้วยใช่มั้ย
คือแบบมันยืดคือแบบมันหลุดออกจากเชือก
แล้วผ้าก็คือมันเปื่อยตรงเนี้ยมันเปื่อย
ละแต่ใส่เวลาออกกำลังกายอยู่บ้านนะไปยิ้ม
นี่ก็ใส่อันอื่นแต่รู้สึกว่าสบายจังไป
ยิ้มแบบนี้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ถ้าอยู่บ้าน
เนี่ยจริงๆอ่ะชุดนอนคูนิกเนี่ยก็จะเป็น
เสื้อเก่าๆเลยนะพอคิดว่าใส่แล้วมันสบาย
แล้วมันอยู่บ้านไม่มีใครเห็นมันก็ขาดๆมัน
ก็โอเคก็นอนอยู่บ้านสบายดีชุดนอนเยิ่ง
เก่ายิ่งดีนั่นไงมันต้องมีบางอย่างที่แบบ
อยู่ได้หลายๆปีใช่อ่ะเดี๋ยวแล้วอย่างครู
เรียมครับครูเรียมปกติเป็นคนที่ใช้ของนาน
มั้ยหรือว่าใช้แป๊บๆแล้วก็ซื้ออันใหม่มา
อันเก่าทิ้งไปสำหรับเรียมนะโทรศัพท์เนี่ย
นานอนานมากอันที่ใช้อยู่ตอนนี้ก็แบบก็นาน
นะแต่ว่าอันนี้แบบเพิ่งจะได้แบบปี 2 ปี
อือฮึแต่ว่ามันมีส่วนประกอบจากเครื่อง
เก่าที่เป็นรุ่นเดียวกันครับเอามาเปลี่ยน
เอามาใส่ให้มันยังใช้ได้อ่ะ
อ๋อแบบเปลี่ยนอะไหล่บางอย่างเวลาแบบหน้า
จอแตกแล้วแบบอีกเครื่องนึงที่แบบอยู่ใน
รุ่นเดียวกันเป็นคนที่ไม่ค่อไม่ค่อยชอบ
เลือกอันใหม่ขนาดโทรศัพท์มยังแบบเออเอา
รุ่นเดิมมันก็เลยเปลี่ยนอะไหลกันได้อือ
ที่แบบเออไม่ชอบเสียเวลาเลือกอ่ะเอารุ่น
เดิมซื้อรองเท้าก็เคยเลือกแล้ว 1 ครั้ง
ครั้งถัดไปไปร้านก็จะแบบพี่มีรุ่นนี้มสี
นี้เขาก็จะบอกว่าหมดไปแล้วค่ะแบบไม่มี
แล้วเราก็จะแบบปวดหัวออต้องเลือกอันใหม่
อีกแล้วเหรอเนี่ยออ
ไม่คุนิกอ่ะถ้าอ่าแล้วอเดี๋ยวนะครับแล้ว
นอกจากโทรศัพท์แล้วเสื้อผ้าล่ะเสื้อผ้า
เมื่อกี้ครูเรียมบอกว่าครูเรียมใช้มาก
กว่า 1 ปีใช่ใช้มากกว่า 1 มากกว่านี่
ประมาณไหน
หูเสื้อสีส้มที่เรียมใส่เมื่อวาน
นี้ตั้งแต่เรียนไปเที่ยวเรียนมาอยู่บ้าน 3
ปีแล้วอันนั้นตอนตั้งแต่เรียนจบมหาลัยอู
แบบไม่ได้นับจริงๆนะแต่มากกว่า 5 ปีอ่ะ
อืมอาจจะมากกว่านั้นได้ซ้ำบางตัวครับแต่
มันก็มีนะมันไม่ใช่ทั้งหมดทุกตัวที่แบบจะ
ใส่แล้วแบบ 5 ปี 8 ปีแต่มันมีอืส่วนมาก
ที่เรียมเปลี่ยนก็จะเป็นเสื้อสีขาวเพราะ
ว่าแบบใส่ไปนานๆสีมันเริ่มแบบไม่ขาวละมัน
เหลืองอมันเหลืองนั่นแหละเสื้อสีขาวเนี่ย
จะอยู่ได้ไม่นานแต่อย่างอื่นน่ะอยู่ได้
นานเดมก็เลยหลังๆก็เลยชอบซื้อเสื้อสีขาว
ใส่เสื้อสีขาวเพราะว่าจะได้แบบเปลี่ยนไป
ด้วยแบบบางทีมันก็แบบเออเนาะมันจะได้ดู
สะอาด
ๆา
คือของคุณนิกเนี่ยสำหรับเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยคุณ
นิกมีอีกเหตุผลนึงที่เปลี่ยนบ่อยเพราะ
ว่าคือจริงๆคูนิกเนี่ยไม่ได้ชอบแฟชั่นมาก
แต่คครูนิคิดว่าเราเปลี่ยนทุกปีมันก็ไป
ตามเทรน์ตามปีเขว่าอ๋อปีนี้ใส่แบบ
นี้ดีเหมือนกับประมาณว่าโอเคนะปีนี้เสื้อ
ลายทางเหมือนอย่างของยกตัวอย่างเสื้อลาย
ทางคือที่ครูเรียมใส่มาแรงูนี้ก็โอเคได้
เดี๋ยวไปหาซื้อใหม่แต่ถ้าไปซื้อใหม่แล้ว
ไม่เอาของเก่าออกจากตู้เสื้อผ้าเนี่ยไม่
มีที่ใส่ครุณนิกก็จะต้องมาดูแล้วว่าคครู
นิกอ่ะก่อนจะซื้อเสื้อผ้าใหม่ครุนิกต้อง
ดูก่อนว่าครูนิกจะเอาเสื้อผ้าอันเก่า
เนี่ยตัวเก่าออกมาได้กี่ตัว
โอ้โหถือว่าครูนิกมีสติมากหลายคนหลายคน
ไม่หลายคนยเห็นชอบซื้อๆเอากลับมาบ้านแล้ว
ก็โไม่มีที่เก็บบางทีก็แบบ
ก่อนก็ไม่งั้นน่ะมันก็เป็นการเก็บเงิน
ด้วยเพราะว่าถ้ามันไม่มีที่จริงๆแต่จริงๆ
อ่ะทุกครั้งอ่ะคุณนิก็จะคิดว่ามันก็จะหา
ได้แหละว่าตัวไหนจะเอาไปบริจาคหรือจะเอา
ไปให้คนอื่นใส่แบบเราไม่ใส่แล้วบางตัวนะ
มีว่าใส่แค่ 1 ครั้ง 2 ครั้ง
ก็เอาไปให้คนอื่นละ
อืมแล้วครูนิกว่าคนที่อยู่รอบๆตัวครูนิก
มีพฤติกรรมมีวิธีการใช้สิ่งของยังไงบ้าง
ใช้แบบแป๊บๆแล้วก็เปลี่ยนหรือว่าใช้แบบ
นานๆแล้วค่อยเปลี่ยนเพึ่งครูนิก
เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่ใช้แป๊บๆแล้วก็เปลี่ยนอื
หมายถึงอะไรคะเสื้อผ้า
โทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์เนี่ยเพื่อนคูนิเนี่ยมาก
กว่าครึ่งนะถ้าใช้ iPhone จะเปลี่ยนทุกปี
โหราคาก็ไม่ถูกเลยนะมันก็ไม่ถูกแต่ว่า
เค้าก็จะไม่ได้เสียเงินเยอะเพราะเหมือน
กับ iPhone นะครับมันจะมีเหมือนกับว่าเอา
เครื่องที่เราใช้ไปให้ที่ศูนย์แล้วเขาก็
จะเหมือนกับบอกราคามาเหมือนเป็นส่วนลดยก
ตัวอย่างเหมือนอย่างเนี่ยเครื่องเก่าคูณ
นิกเอาไปเขาจะให้สวนลด 5,000 บาทมันก็ไม่
ได้จ่ายเงินเต็มแล้วถ้าเรายิ่งมีรุ่นใหม่
รุ่นล่าสุดก่อนอันใหม่ที่ออกมาเนี่ยมันก็
จะได้ลดเยอะขึ้นใช่อืเหมือนก็จ่ายเงิน
เพิ่มไม่ไม่ไม่ได้เท่ากับราคาเต็มของ
เครื่องที่ใหม่ล่าสุดใช่ก็คือเหมือนกับ
ว่าไปอัปเกรดอืแบนั้นก็ได้ใช่ครับแล้วก็
เพราะ iPhone เหมือนเค้ามีเปลี่ยนพวกชิป
หรือความจำความเร็วมันเพิ่มขึ้นเพื่อน
คครูนิเก็จะบอกว่าโอ๊ยเนี่ยมันก็คือมัน
รุ่นใหม่มาทุกปีมันก็ดีขึ้นทุกปีอืก็
เปลี่ยนเป็นสิไม่เห็นเป็นอะไรใช่อืตอนนี้
ก็แล้วแล้วอีกแบบกลุ่มนึงล่ะคะที่แบบใช้
นานๆอันนี้เค้ามีความคิดเกี่ยวกับเรื่อง
นี้ยังไงคือคือกลุ่มที่ใช้นานๆเนี่ยที่
ครูนิกเพื่อนครูนิกนะหรือคนรอบข้างเกลุ่ม
ที่ใช้นานๆเนี่ยจริงๆอ่ะจะไม่ใช่คนไทยอื
อืส่วนใหญ่ก็จะเป็นคนคนต่างชาติเค้าก็บอก
ว่ามันยังใช้ได้ไม่เห็นเป็นไรเพื่อนคูนิ
นะมีอยู่คนนึงหน้าจอโทรศัพท์แตกแบบแตกเลย
นะไม่เปลี่ยนหน้าจอเพราะว่ามันก็ยังกดได้
มีภาพเห็นได้ทุกอย่างเบอกไม่เห็นเป็นไร
เลยไม่ต้องไปเสียเงินซ่อมด้วยซ่อมแล้วก็
เสียตังโอเคหน้าจอดีขึ้นแต่ยังไงก็เนี่ย
มันแตกก็ยังเห็นอยู่อ๋อก็คือยังใช้ได้
อยู่ใช้ได้คือสำหรับครูนิกับครูนิคิดว่า
คนต่างชาติ
เขาใช้ของเหมือนกับใช้ของนานกว่าเพราะว่า
เขาเห็นว่ามันยังใช้ได้ก็ใช้ไปเค้าจะไม่
ยึดติดกับ
เอ่อกับเทรนด์กับความทันสมัยว่าจะอะไรออก
มาใหม่ต้องซื้อทันทีเพราะคุณนี้ก็อืมคคุณ
นี้ก็เห็นด้วยนะใช่แล้วมันอาจจะเป็น
เรื่องส่วนบุคคลด้วยเนาะก็ไม่ได้ถูกไม่
ได้ผิดหรอกแต่ว่าใครที่ชอบแบบไหนก็จะเป็น
แบบนั้นก็จะทำแบบที่ตัวเองชอบแค่นั้นเอง
แต่ว่าก็จะเห็นได้ว่าถ้าเกิดเป็นคนไทย
หรือว่าคนที่อยู่อยู่รอบๆตัวเราบางทีเข้า
ก็จะมีดิมก็รู้สึกนะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยเป็นนัก
ช้อปเท่าที่แบบเออใช่เท่าที่แบบรู้ก็คือ
มีคนที่แบบไปเที่ยวแบบฝรั่งเศสหรือประเทศ
อื่นๆที่คนที่ขายของอยู่ที่นั่นน่ะสามารถ
พูดภาษาไทยได้อ
แล้วคนไทยคนไทยก็จะชอบเฮ้ยพูดภาษาไทยได้
หรอแล้วก็ซื้อของ
ใช่ใช่ก็เอ่อยกตัวอย่างครับอันนี้ก็คือ
สำหรับครูนิกเนี่ยน้ำหอมครูนิกจะใช้น้ำ
หอมทีละขวดก็คือถ้าซื้อขวดนึงมาใช้ให้หมด
แล้วซื้อใหม่เพื่อนคครูนิกนะมีน้ำหอม 10
ขวดอืแล้วก็วันนี้จะฉีดอันนี้วันนี้จะฉีด
อันนั้นเราก็ยังไม่หมดสักอันเลยนะอันใหม่
มาละอืนักช้อตัวจริงนักช้อตัวจริงบางคน
อย่างของคูนิเนี่ยถ้าเกี่ยวกับพวกครีมทา
หน้าพวกสกินแครคูนิก็จะมีเหมือนกับเป็น
ครีมแล้วก็เป็นโฟมล้างหน้าอาจจะมีเป็นพวก
เซรั่มนิดหน่อยแค่นั้นเพื่อนครูนิกบางคน
นะมีครีมทาหน้า 4 อันยังไม่รวมเซรัมนะอื
แล้วก็มีโฟมล้างหน้าอีก 3 อัน 3 หลอดคุณ
นี้ก็คิดว่ามีใช้ยังไงเออใช้ยังไงทำไม
ต้องมาใช้อะไรเยอะแยะแบบออมันไม่เหมือน
กันไงก็อันเนี้ยอันเนี้ยเอาาไว้ละมีอยู่
คนนึงนะอันเนี้ยโฟมล้างหน้าแต่ล้างแค่
หน้าผากเพราะว่าหน้าผากอ่ะมันมันกว่าตรง
แก้ม
อืรายละเอียดเยอะมากรายละเอียดเยอะใช่
เหมือนกับมีเวลาว่าง
มากใช่แต่ถ้าทำของมาขายให้คนไทยหรือว่าคน
ทางเอเชียเรียมก็คิดว่าขายดีนะทางเรานี่
แบบเออช้อปเก่งซื้อของเก่งใช่ของคือคนไทย
คนนี้คิดว่าถ้าเเห็นใครรีวิวหรือคนดังๆ
ใช้อ่ะจะใช้ตามคนไทยจะตามง่ายเหมือนกับ
ใช้คำว่าอะไรจะใช้คำว่าหลอกขายก็ไม่ใช่
แต่แค่บอกว่าอันเนี้ยดีอันดับ 1 หรือไป
จ้างคนรีวิวของให้แล้วคนนั้นดังคนก็ซื้อ
ใช่ซื้อมาแล้วไม่ดีก็แค่ไม่ซื้อต่อแค่
นั้นแต่ว่าแบบก็ก็ขายได้แล้วครั้ง
นึงใช่ก็นั่นแหละครับคุณนี้ก็เลยคิดว่าคน
ไทยเนี่ยเวเวลาเกี่ยวกับของใช้เนี่ย
สำหรับคนรอบข้างของครูนิกเนี่ยก็เปลี่ยน
บ่อยอืเปลี่ยนบ่อยว่าใช้แล้วก็ไม่รอให้
หมดซื้ออันใหม่มาแทนอย่างลิปสติกมี 24
อย่างเงี้ยแต่อันนั้นเข้าใจว่ามันเป็นมัน
เป็นเพราะว่าจะสทาสีเดียวตลอดกาลมันไม่
ได้แต่ละงานมันไม่เหมือนกันใช่ใช่มั้ยจะ
เล่าให้ฟังเดี๋ยวรีมจะเล่าให้ฟังเรื่อง
นี้ได้เลยอๆๆๆสีแต่ละสีไม่เหมือนกันน้ำ
หอมแต่ละกลิ่นไปคนละงานอะไรอย่างงี้ก็ไม่
เหมือนกันใช่คุณนิกก็เข้าใจแต่คือสำหรับ
คุณนิกแคคิดว่าน้ำหอมอ่ะเหตุผลที่คุณนิก
ฉีดเพราะคุณนิกเหงื่อออกเยอะแล้วบางทีมัน
เหม็นเหงื่อคุณนิก็เลยแค่ฉีดไม่ให้ได้
กลิ่นเหงื่อ
อืมนี่แหละค่ะที่คุยกันวันนี้ก็คือเกี่ยว
กับการซื้อของแล้วใช้ได้นานหรือเปล่าหรือ
ว่าซื้อแล้วใช้แป๊บเดียวแล้วก็เปลี่ยนใช่
ครับอันนี้ก็สำหรับหัวข้อวันนี้ที่เราคุย
กันใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะครู
นิครับต้องเจอกันใหม่ในคลิปเจอกันใหม่
ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะโอเคได้โอเคครับครู
เรียมไว้เจอกันใหม่สวัสดีค่ะ
สว